I'll call that [ __ ] yes I did yes I did
Avengers in game I call that title so
fast I called that title and I'm
actually there for right now I'm
supposed to be going to flying into
Akron Ohio visit my girlfriend but my
flight was delayed postponed all I kind
of [ __ ] so I'm just flying directly I
just booked another flight flying
directly into Cleveland and just drive
down there to see her what'd you like to
get me there earlier which is chemical
thing so very cool so okay so Avengers
infinity where vendors before I'm
excited man like I like the idea that
it's going in the direction that it's
just like things are really really bad
right because it wouldn't make a whole
lot of sense if like half the life in
the universe gets blinked out of
existence and they're like what I mean
things could be worse though you know
like it wouldn't make a whole lot if
that was the case so it is kind of cool
but looking over the trailer like
Hawkeye looks amazing as Ronan I love
wood I love black widows wine like
Thanos told us exactly what he would do
which is exactly what he did
and he wiped out half the life in the
universe that was that was that was
pretty cool um honestly
there's not enough to really know what's
gonna happen in the movie it's just that
the trailer is exactly what a trailer
should be hey guys so like here's an
idea of what the movies about ships dark
and pretty much all hope is lost
so it's pretty cool and it's and I
really enjoyed that part of it you know
I really enjoyed that element of it um
if I were a gambling man you know if I
if I had if I had to play some bets you
know on on what direction things were
going I don't know I mean look let's
console would you sit down for a second
cuz we got about another hour and a half
two hours before my flight acts reports
but before it takes off rather we got
alright so if I was a game leader
if I were going to be a gambling man
here it'll it'll basically be what
amounts to like the New Avengers
essentially you know you'll have the of
the original Avengers team basically you
know those characters are back if that
was really the big thing that came out
of infinity war was that it was just the
original Avengers from your left but
they're not enough to defeat Thanos so
they never work which means that either
the entirety of the film hinges on
Captain Marvel either is just gonna be
one great big huge hey Captain Marvel we
love you video but movie which is fine I
guess you know or something else was
gonna have to happen Carol Danvers is
cool I made her some I'm excited to see
her film the issue that I have here is
it doesn't make any sense to give her a
solo film that highlights her character
and then you know six months later put
her in another film that highlights her
character yet again like the Avengers
film is an ensemble film it's not a solo
film so it's designed to focus on each
character equally except for Iron Man
finding soso outside to that like it
would make any sense to basically create
two solo movies featuring Captain Marvel
um I think that she'll be a powerhouse
against Thanos
I think she'll stand a better chance at
beating him than anybody else I think
she'll come the closest of the closest
to defeating him battle dig show
outright beat him or at least if you
won't be the one to fix everything I
think that you know it'll it can go
either way right like we know that Scott
Lang is in the movie which begs the
question how does Scott Lang get out of
the port of the quantum realm now here's
here's the thing so the quantum realm in
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe is not
like anything my initial thought was
that it was basically the microwave that
was my whole idea of it okay especially
the Quadro grounds the micro much like
it's just a super small
you know universe that exists out there
you know it's it's a realm it's a
dimension so here's how this works so a
Marvel Comics imagine you have a circle
right lay and I use this example when
we're talking like when we were talking
about the one above all tomorrow during
the too powerful for the Marvel Universe
movie use but imagine you have a circle
and imagine that circle is called you
know MC that's the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is what that circle is inside
that big circle you have smaller circles
smaller circle might be Asgard another
small circle might be the realm of
Dormammu with Dark Dimension
and another small circle might be the
quantum realm we don't know what the
quantum realm is about and that's the
biggest problem we don't really know
what it's about what it's capable of we
don't know if it's pure energy we don't
know if that's for the the Enigma forces
right like the Enigma force is basically
this force of energy that it bonds
itself to a person and they become
captain universe they could pretty much
do anything yeah they can do almost
anything then once you transmit matter
or like all I kind of cool stuff why
energy production like you would rush
the power of Carol Danvers we don't know
if Scott Lang has that we don't know if
the quantum realm is this realm that
allows people to act if it's like a
hallway of doors and it's like it's like
the m'kraan crystal basically right you
know like in Marvel Comics you have
what's called the uncon crystal and they
have crown crystal is a literal hallway
of doors like it's you haven't instantly
the center of it you have the white-hot
room which is where the Phoenix force
hangs out but um but it's basically a
hallway of doors you can enter the
m'kraan crystal and access any other
universe from the m'kraan
we don't know if that's the case the
negative zones the exact same way
negative zone Imam what comics pretty
much the same way the kids in the house
is like an actual universe with aliens
and so on and so forth there's life of
it but with the quantum world we don't
know if that's the case the quantum
realm would allow its user to access you
know to basically create portals that
would allow them access any other
universe in existence and if that's true
Scott Lang holds the secret to freeing
everybody from soul world so you know I
don't know maybe that maybe that was his
way out I honestly have no earthly clue
you don't have no idea maybe Tony Stark
creates Infinity stones
maybe they invoke time travel I mean
honestly I would say the cosmic entities
will probably step in or the or the
Living Tribunal will probably step in
you know it creates an imbalance of
magical energy I'm not really sure
there's any number of ways they can go
because we know the cosmic entities were
the ones who created the Infinity swords
right so like eternity infinity oblivion
and end or not sorry eternity infinity
entropy and death were the ones who
created the cosmic I'm sorry I created
the Infinity stones and the model said
I'm at he was pretty sure that's right
and because they were the ones who did
that then it turns into a wool one of us
do they want to take their power back or
something like that what happened to
them in the first place
you know are they still there are they
gone do they just not care what's what
goes on I mean we don't really know what
the cases with those with those guys but
the fact remains that there's a litany
of possibilities here in terms of how
this movie can end I mean I person would
want to see like Avengers forever
basically like give me Avengers forever
like I would want to see that you know
where they invoke the time stone and
they bring in Avengers in the past the
present in the future all together to
fight against Thanos like that would be
pretty that'd be pretty awesome maybe
too convoluted for this movie but it
would still be pretty cool
honestly I don't know how it'll end I
mean there's no there's no
there's not enough information to make
you gasp there's just not enough
information here to be able to figure
out how this baby's gonna end it's not
possible there's just it's too crazy
there's too much going on it's just too
I don't know
as you said there's there's just there's
not enough information there to be able
to make a guess on on how this film is
gonna end I mean personally if they
invoke time travel I think Steve Rogers
will stay in the past right like the
only book time travel they'll go back to
like World War two or they'll somehow
pass through World War two and Steve
Rogers will stay that or or okay Scott
okay so Scott Lang in the quantum realm
all right Scott Lang shrunk down in the
quantum realm and he that's where he is
right now and at the time that I'm
making this video hopefully on between
Avengers infinity war and Avengers 40
now let's say he learns to harness the
power of the quantum them or at least
navigated like understand you know the
basics in which it works now at that
point let's say he learned how to create
like portals to places right like the
quantum realm is a realm that allows its
user to access all space and time so you
can go anywhere throughout the history
of the universe and in the universe of
the current moment by traveling to the
continent right so you can go 50 years
in the past to the other side of the
universe or even go a million years in
the past on earth you can do all these
different things inside the quantum
realm what if that's the case like what
do that's what happens um and he figured
that out and he goes back to them he
goes to the Avengers says we can fix
this we can undo this we can we can
basically go back to the past and change
things and so usually quantum realm he
travels into the past with the other
Avengers Captain America stays in the
past he decides to stay in world war two
he doesn't want to lose he's like no I
I'm staying where I'm staying with
Marvel I'm staying with Peggy Carter and
lives a life with him right like stays
there now what that does is it gives
them the ability to go back at any point
in time and retrieve him and to say hey
look we know you wanted to stay here but
like we need you now like we have to
have Captain America because we need a
guy who can punch really hard you know
but but nonetheless um there's a lot of
things that you can do with with the
movie uh god I believe this man hawkeye
looks badass though like that's that's
what's so conditioned to me Hawkeye look
so bad I feel like Hawkeye is a guy that
nobody ever takes seriously he's just
like kind of the guy who's there and in
reality he's just a guy who's really
accurate you know he's just he's either
super accurate guy amazing at darts but
uh
and it's kind of like okay but like they
dumb him down they kind of play him down
I feel like he could potentially be a
guy who changes things like Hawkeye gets
the Infinity Gauntlet like that would be
cool cuz all the people that I peg to
get the Infinity Gauntlet and Avengers
four are gone like I was like okay well
then Black Panther will probably get it
cuz he's super smart he knows how to use
it like Panthers gone
well then spider-man will be a really
good tribute like it would - spider-man
like that'd be a cool thing you know it
looks like this kid with great power
must come great responsibility any lords
the true meaning of the phrase or so on
he's gone like he's he was bested like
everybody except the original Avengers
has just Dustin gone and in debt so I
don't know I mean I'm curious what do
you how do you guys think this is gonna
unfold let me know down in the comments
section how do you guys think this will
end because I'm really curious to see
what theories you guys come up with I
mean this is me off top my head sitting
in an airport with no time to really sit
down and analyze the trailer and figure
it out just kind of me talking you know
and whatnot but let me know you guys dig
down in the in the comments section you
know by the way I shaved okay look at me
I look good when I shave I don't look
very good on camera
I look good when I shave leave my guys
ah there's birds here somewhere anyway
guys look I bring this video to an end
and I will catch you all later please